it's time to babble the [__] on
[Music]
live from the world-famous
improv it's Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
it's just so it's weird it's just weird
cuz it's new you add this to the weed
and I'm just like what happened why is
the love it so it looks so much better
why does the microphones work I know and
it's Friday night in Hollywood so let's
babble the [__] on I'm so far Smith I'm
Ralph Garman and welcome to the improv
new home man yeah interesting as [__]
holy [__] what was it Jon Lovitz is here
ladies and gentlemen
I'll go before you come here that's what
I say we're just [__] hold it yeah
yeah it's they've been improv right here
on Melrose a lot of history it's been
here for eons and whatnot I remember as
a kid watching evening at the improv
every night is where the original brick
wall is yeah well be honest is the brick
wall that launched a thousand [__]
careers and cable shows yeah so it's
nice to kind of be here as well what you
smoking tonight what's your string with
Scott Walker
[Applause]
[Music]
am i coming off as stony or something no
I'm just curious
you just got cured I just wanna know
what I'm in for tonight that's Chi
walking [__] I'm all about [__] like
it's a trap it's all it's all good man
hey before we get rolling
can I do something a little sentimental
you're not gonna propose to me are ya
this is the last weekend we have Megan
with us yeah
Quinlan who's run my life for the last
five years is dropping this big baby to
go east and have a little baby of her
own so this is the last weekend she can
be out here you missed it nice things
about you saying nice things about this
is Megan without whom nothing happens
and she's you care you can leave now yes
all we've been doing for [__] weeks
is crying about this but we found a way
to work through it and whatnot she's
going back east to start a family and
stuff after raising mine for you know
last five years and so it was because it
was becoming a real problem about like
it was it was like misery at the house
there was buckets of [__] tears
because people didn't realize how I were
think about how the [__] we're gonna
function without each other but one
morning or one night it came to me and I
told her the next morning I says Megan
why don't you Jarvis the job and she's
like what do you mean I was like an Iron
Man Jarvis ain't there like Jarvis is
just a voice and [__] and most of the
stuff you do is like you know call me to
be like go to this interview or find me
on iChat or something like that so you
could pretty much keep doing like 85 90
percent of the job the only thing
missing is us driving around together
that's it but you could keep doing the
job and we could pretend like you didn't
move to the other side of the country
and [__] and I could feel like Tony
Stark
so that's really what it's all about for
you very much the closer I get to start
so a stark reality so she she's leaving
so with that sad but the good news is
like she's not leaving leaving or it
might just trick him I see you're
tricking yourself Am I she's absolutely
leaving no don't say that
you're gonna make her cry yeah and there
she say look so you're gonna walk around
with a headset all the time you'll be
just talking in your ear telling you how
to live your life [__] yeah I'm look I'm
already going bald so imma put these
headphones on look like Lobot from
Empire Strikes Back good idea I must be
sitting around going like this all the
time while Megan talks them in my ear so
in any event Thank You Megan for all the
times you made this show run and whatnot
and we'll miss you of course physically
but we love you as well yes thank you
[Applause]
guys for showing up tonight a sold-out
night here at the improv it seems like
wherever we go you guys show up and we
can't tell you how much Kevin
appreciates that I appreciate it and my
mustache appreciate it thank you Tom
what's going on in fact so many people
on Twitter assaulting both you and I go
on what Kevin Smith's on the road you
can't [__] do the show with someone
else you little [__] [__] yes step
to the mic garment and what most folks
didn't realize is tell him what we what
you've been doing look Kevin was out
with his movie the groovy the super
groovy cartoon movie some of those cats
and I was in New Mexico shooting Seth
MacFarlane's new comedy called a million
ways to die in the west seth was kind
enough to put me in his film so I was
shooting for a week in New Mexico and I
go back in June to finish up and that's
why my hair looks ridiculous and I have
a mustache because I'm playing a cowboy
in the 1800s and apparently they were
[__] up then so I had to look [__]
up but the minute it's it's it's wrapped
I'm gonna cut my hair and shave my face
and I'll be beautiful again thank God
you act that you're like that's why my
hair is [__] up and I got facial hair
what's my excuse I don't even have like
I'm in a movie [__] I'm just
like I'm middle-aged
we kick off the show each and every week
with something we like to do where we
give shout outs of people who come
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions in the
room it's called the shout outs
it's a shout out Kevin and Brown so get
Utah cows
[Music]
get your [__] out get your [__] out I'd
open ignite jitters yeah you did and
here I'll tell you what went through my
mind as I was about to fellate this mic
I was I was sitting there thinking
legends have stood here Jerry Seinfeld
probably held that mic and built a
career I'm being funny and my bid is
like I'll suck this off because the bars
lower now Jerry are Adam and Matt here
from Birmingham England
[Music]
that's his [__] sir that is his myth
he's only got a few he's only got a few
recurring bits can you let the man have
his jokes I feel like The Little Mermaid
man like
my voice was stolen
Adam writes me and my friend and Matt
will be coming to show from Birmingham
England we've been in the US for over
two months now I'm pretty sure your visa
has expired
yeah really times you two go home now
we started in Boston made our way here
where the highlights of the trip not so
much for Matt he hasn't listened to the
show but he'll survive writes Adam we
have an unexpected day in Los Angeles to
come to the show and we have nowhere to
stay so if you could possibly have a
shout out in Ralph's Paul McCartney
voice convincing any American ladies to
give us a place to stay for the night
well if they could be great if you gave
them a place to stay after all that's
from England and everything from Eagle
it's just great there you go
good luck fellas yeah I saw a cardboard
box in the alley on the way in by the
way if you don't get lucky like one dude
who listens to the podcast like it's
cool for him because it's like I know
what I'm in for the other dude it's like
we're in Los Angeles we could be putting
[__] dicks in our mouths and getting
away with it because when in LA put it
in your mouth
but instead we're sitting here watching
these [__] clowns I don't even know
who's this guy's he play a sport
unless one dude must be very confused
David Greg and Christina are you guys
here I guess Jon Lovitz is here tonight
then the Tiki lounge at Disneyland in
the Tiki Tiki Tiki Tiki Tiki Room talk
about that yeah in the to eat eat the
birds that sing to each other yes how
you love that man because you just sit
there it's not like a ride where you
gonna lie you said magic pineapple juice
ability [__] birds are all right
Kristina writes I'm here with my husband
David and my brother Greg my brother
just graduated college yesterday Oh
and I knew the best way to celebrate his
graduation would be with you two and a
bunch of dick jokes yes nothing says
higher education like Hollywood
babble-on I was wondering if the Germans
can congratulate my brother on a job
well done and tell him what his new
post-grad life has in store for him you
guys are the best Christina what did you
graduate with sir what kind of degree a
bachelor's in drinking history you have
a history degree well good for you that
you can open up a little history shop
now
history sells now man doesn't it yeah
[__] yeah history is on fire here's what
I say you do with your history degree
yeah I never forget your history I never
forget it except the part in the late
30s and early 40s if you could cut that
part of history out we would really
appreciate that's the boring part is
important nothing happened
Austria was not important country and
Poland yeah we we had a guy who was a
little overeager then but he's gone he's
gone yeah he's gone in there in the
bunker with Eva
but now it's all [__] and chocolate
that's right
sometimes we dip the [__] in the
chocolate yeah yes well congratulations
on your history degrees right I wish you
all the best
Karen Kelly and Eric who are you guys
here this is from Karen tonight I am
celebrating Mother's Day belatedly with
my son who's in the Navy and my
beautiful daughter my son was able to
take leave this weekend and his gift to
me was an evening with Ralph and Kevin
oh what a shitty Mother's yeah really
could have gone to ProFlowers and gotten
some roses I'm really nice man or
Lottery scratch-off it was the perfect
gift and I couldn't be happier
yeah loston mm-hmm I have the best kids
a mom could ever ask for they the loves
of my life if there's any way you could
give them a shout-out I would so greatly
appreciate it when I'm missing my kids I
know I can think back to this special
night and smile Oh [__] hey man
between the Megan thing in this I'm
gonna cry all night long Ken Bain give a
shout-out to my daughter Kelly
nothing says maternal love like bein
tell her how much I love her and how
proud I am to have her as my daughter
and if you'll Howser could give a
shout-out to my son Eric that would be
amazing she writes so for Kelly bein
okay and for Eric
Huell Howser Oh Kelly
this is my friend you're in the Navy I
like sailors they're amazing Karen
writes here I can't tell you what he's
doing due to security clearance [__] out
of here we'll wait what branch is this
dude I think the SEAL Team six hey man
are you gonna be a seat whoa
don't tell us but just
[Laughter]
you see this at any point tonight you
tell me the duck where let me finish
mine Oh your mother loves you that's it
you get to sleep in bunks with other
sailors that's amazing
I love seamen no one cared who I was
till I gave out the eyes welcome guys
and happy mother's day Karen by the way
Eric also sent an email asking for the
same thing for his mom a shout-out isn't
that nice she really doesn't have the
best kids really very sweet but he was
like don't ask her what she does it's
tough see that's right I can't tell
anybody how about Chris and his sister
from Albany New York who you guys here
from Albany to see you with my little
sister who's also coming to the show
last robbery she joined the Navy
do you know Eric doing a [__] USO
show here no I'm Bob Hope everybody how
you doing yes I did a Bob Hope
impression you heard me
she's been all over the globe globe for
the past nine or ten months and finally
returned to the US I'm a huge HBO fan so
what better way to celebrate seeing my
little sister again who's been on a ship
since last year then by spending an
evening with two guys who get paid to
swim like sailors yeah could Ralph have
David Bowie tell my sister how much our
whole family loves her and is proud for
her for defending our country Chris well
I think that's appropriate I think David
Bowie could work something out for that
is very patriotic yes he is we have
little Bowie music thank you for
defending your country
you also sleep with semen in a big
floating four house in your country and
defending us from depending us from Oh
[Music]
no it's a new place don't rub the
microphone on your genitals
[Music]
welcome and thank you for serving your
country I was very pleased with the
patriotic men to be all we also get
emails from all around the world we like
to read out a couple of them at the
start of the show
it's my email bag featuring Kevin's
reactions first email is from pepper
from Newcastle Oklahoma just outside of
Moore of course you all know what
happened there with the the horrible
tornado the head went through Moore and
pepper writes he lives in Newcastle just
north of Moore he's been volunteering in
the neighborhood he said I was walking
through the mangled metal and debris
yesterday and I saw something that made
me smile I bent down and picked up the
bonus disc from Kevin's clerks to DVD
still intact enough to record you can't
kill clerks - I know a lot of people are
saying to pray for us but I don't think
prayer is what we need right now we need
people helping one another we will
rebuild the city of Moore and they'll be
stronger because of it so please keep
the laughter going and help us smile at
a time when so many have lost everything
that's from pepper and we have a lot of
listeners in Oklahoma so we want to send
them all our best real quickly by the
way if you get a chance Red Cross org
slash donate if you want to give some
money towards the relief effort would be
a nice thing or you can text the word
REDCROSS to 90999 and that's an
automatic $10 donation so I just wanted
to get that out there because I know we
have a lot of listeners in Oklahoma
truly this email comes from Matthew
dunwyn who writes I was just wondering
why there isn't a SModcast theme range
of cereals oh my god what a great
[__] idea I knew you'd like that
given Kevin's well-known love of cereal
I can't believe there isn't smeary allah
vailable
well he really sounds like a venereal
disease yeah doc what is it I have I've
been having a discharge and I've got
spots yes I'm sorry you've got Muriel
guppy
I'm telling you dude like if they can
make them like little me shaped
characters I would fulfill my dream I've
always wanted to eat myself so I could
just spoon fulls and one man Matthew
writes I'd love to buy a box of
Hollywood babble those I wouldn't and I
wouldn't either
there you go what happened I don't know
did you guys write that letter you just
like I like cereal too and we also got
emails for me to do specific voices in
certain situations one of them is to
have a celebrity read the Green Lantern
oath for those of you who are comic book
geeks you know the Green Lantern has to
recharge his ring every 24 hours in
order to get it to work and he has to
say a certain poem in order to get his
ring recharged it's kind of gay when you
think about it really
this one comes from Brad Campbell it's
time for Ralph's Green Lantern oath
[Music]
brad writes I love your Charlton Heston
impression I would love to hear mr.
Heston recite the Green Lantern oath
he's from Shreveport Louisiana well I'll
be happy to happy to help in brightest
day a blackest night no evil shall
escape my sight let those who worship
evils might beware my power
Toyland Green Lantern's light there you
go that's for you Brad every week we
also say goodbye to some people who've
been in show business who have left us
and we like to give them send-offs
people in music television and films
it's a segment we respectfully call the
Tinseltown stiffs and now another
edition of
[Music]
they will be missed do you mind yeah I'm
I was I was rocking a little Street
performance why a lot of people died
this week just a fact I'm not making a
judgment call sure it's good for the
show but I consider that a byproduct
Steve Forrest you may not know the name
but if you grew up in the 70s or watch
the reruns at all of a TV show called
SWAT you know who's DeForest was he was
the leader of the SWAT team named Hondo
was his character and he had a
catchphrase when they would go to the
scene of a crime he'd always say let's
roll and they'd all jump in that SWAT
van and they would take off and and
fight was that that was the greatest
theme ever in history as a little
appreciation for Steve I thought I'd
play you the the intro the real version
wasn't good enough not as good as the
real thing I think we had a little video
this is the beginning of SWAT and you'll
see Steve so you'll recognize him but
this is the greatest theme song in my
opinion in TV history
[Music]
yes the forest passed away at the age of
87 I resolved is my dearest he was in
that as well
yeah he was he played her boyfriend for
a while a singer passed away this week
was better known as a songwriter he
wrote a bunch of songs for a bunch of
stars in the 70s and 80s Righteous
Brothers Helen Reddy Johnny Mathis Tom
Jones Tony Orlando and Dawn Three Dog
Night Paul Anka's name was Alan O'Day
and he had a hit of his own in 1977 it
was a single called undercover angel
remember that song remember dude it's in
my top 20 playlist on iTunes I play it
relentless you're [__] kidding under
covering again not even that fantasy not
to make a judgment call on your version
of it but we have it a little bit of the
actual if you like right here mr. Allen
or Dave passed away this week at 72
[Music]
I said there's a weird song because I
was like a dude [__] a ghost
basically is that what you got yeah
she's like an imaginary woman who comes
doom and has sex with him in his bed
oh it's literal that means under the
covers of a bed yes I was just like I'm
keeping it on the down-low says a lot
more about you than it does about the
song so peppy for that too and then he
meets a real girl and then he kicks
undercover angel to the [__] curb
wait a sec what else do you do
he also wrote Rock and Roll Heaven by
the Righteous Brothers that song Angie
baby for Helen Reddy had a bunch of hits
in the cell what's a real baby Angie
baby Angie baby
so you can sing and there's no you asked
me Verena also passed away this week was
a legendary rock and roll bass player
named Trevor bolder he used to be the
bass player for a band called Uriah Heep
but more importantly he was the bass
player for the spiders from Mars David
Bowie's backup band in the seventies he
played on all of Bowie's albums in the
seventies hunky dory Ziggy Stardust
Aladdin Sane he was known not only for
being an excellent bass player but
having the most [__] insane sideburns
anyone's ever grown I bought a little
piece of video in because I couldn't do
it justice just to describe to you what
it looked like but here's here's Trevor
bolder playing the bass on Jeanne Jeanne
great old Bowie song and you got to
check out his sideburns cuz I'm telling
you they're I want to have sex with his
sideburns they're awesome here's a
little piece of video
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah nobody wanted to [__] is that burns
do I care insane
I want to [__] your sideburns and lastly
Los Angeles legend passed away this week
the doors keyboardist and co-founder Ray
Manzarek of the band The Doors died at
74 this week after about gonna learn
that it was a big life man and he lived
very long 274 is pretty good age yeah he
probably would like more I'm guessing we
all were and I would have liked more for
him but like what a [__] legend man
like you're leaving this life here like
I created the door yeah remember Jim
Morrison yeah him and I were buddies and
then we created this band that still is
one of the biggest rock bands ever to
come out of Los Angeles yeah they were
students together at UCLA that's where
they met and the Venice Beach and they
put the band together along with Roger
they were film schools too yeah and he
was sort of the musical cornerstone in
that band he they didn't have a bass
player so he used to have to take one
hand and play bass and then the other
hand he would riff on the other keyboard
playing all the lead stuff on the piano
and organ pieces and light my fire of
course was their big hit in 1967 went to
number one and it just made them a
legend and then just a couple years
later marcin passed away or did he yeah
makes you think doesn't it he went on to
be a big producer No all I've ever heard
is like oh he died oh no man to what he
did and live he died there's a big
counterculture said he faked it man
really yeah he was in Paris and he
decided just to check out and disappear
and he was like he went gone with the
wind not he wasn't in Gone with the Wind
I was in an Andy Kaufman kind of way
there are people who think any Kaufman
faked his death yeah Elvis - I've never
heard that about Elvis Elvis as well
yeah we all we saw him we all new Lords
did we
you know you can counter any argument
with that line you can take that home
with you say me baby you know your mom
and are going to dinner or are you makes
people wonder huge bucket a win for
romance here's a little taste of men's
Eric on the keyboards for light my fire
one of their early television
appearances
[Music]
you see the Oliver Stone version The
Doors movie yeah man damn yeah did a
good job I thought he'll be missed big
bucket of won every rustle boards every
week we also talked about a celebrity
that's got out of their own way able to
get out of their own ego their own head
and actually reach out and help someone
else
it happened so rarely we like to
spotlight it with a second we call
Hollywood helper yeah that's the wrong
jingle for therefore the segment there
we go first show new club we'll work it
out it's fine there's some kinks this
week our Hollywood helper is Dame Helen
Mirren the British actress Helen Mirren
a great story there was a ten-year-old
boy named Oliver Burton in the UK who
has Down syndrome and leukemia and he
has been recently given a terminal
diagnosis his one dying wish was to have
tea with the Queen in Buckingham Palace
queen elizabeth ii couldn't work it into
her schedule [__] [__]
nothing personal guys
go Birmingham my favorite football club
they all have football clubs Oh Queen
Elizabeth - she's busy she's busy
counting her money so she couldn't fit
every schedule so Helen Mirren is
currently in the West End doing a play
where she plays Queen Elizabeth in the
play okay so she invited young Oliver
backstage to have tea and cake with her
in costume and in character so in
essence he would get to meet the Queen
but didn't know that she's really Helen
there I'm just saying
[Applause]
Jesus please forgive him it's I didn't
give him Down syndrome what are you
turning on me for it's a fact
I've sat next to you for years and
listen you say referenceable things that
one is sending us both to him I didn't I
barely even said anything I just made a
noise I'm just saying
waiter Chris in a new place saying in
Oliver's case you know fair enough so
it's so we could have met Russell Brand
it said Oh Oliver meet the Queen is nice
to meet you I've got a scarf on I look
like I smell and he would say and he
would be happy I'm just saying no that's
so nice of her though it is very nice of
her
she even knighted him backstage now
she's [__] pushing it right that's
what I'm thinking all right Dame Helen
why don't you just relax you're not the
real Queen that was that kid I'd be like
now I have the license to kill
[Laughter]
Catherine the mother of Oliver said Dame
Helen was brilliant she stayed in
character the whole time so
congratulations the Helen Mirren you
pulled one over on a ten-year-old kid
with Down syndrome
you made him believe congratulations
Helen Mirren you're a wonderful actress
you fooled a dying boy to thinking
you're the queen good for you
hope you're happy how do you sleep at
night I met her she's such a [__]
cool lady she's like one of the boys
kind of curses and very very did she
night you know she I don't even think
she played the Queen at that point but
what a [__] sweet thing to do and do
you think the Queen is sitting in the
palace now just like you're dead Mary
and like now I'm gonna go dressed as you
to some [__] place I'm gonna go to a
truck stop [__] glory hole just like
Helen [__] Mirren I'm gonna need dick
and you're gonna deal with it like what
happened to her majesty
little corgis you happen next to her and
then you shut the [__] up you know in
future films when you make a movie
there's a lot of people involved right
you got people on the set you've got
people who edit the thing and people who
score it and there's hundreds of pairs
of eyes who look at a film before it
reaches the audience and yet invariably
week after week we find scenes in these
major motion pictures that have moments
that are just don't [__] belong in in
you you heard the jingle before it's
it's [__] that should not say this
week's [__] that should not be comes
from Zachary Hoopa from who from
Columbia South Carolina he says my entry
for [__] that should not be comes from
Hulk Hogan's magnum opus from the early
90s
mr. nanny I know if you've ever seen mr.
nanny Hulkster plays a former wrestler
mmm he's got range
who takes a job as a nanny for a bunch
of kids and boy that premise never gets
old doesn't it we've seen it fairly
recently no yes we have
mr. nanny from 1993 features of the
Hulkster on a motorcycle driving through
the the woods on his way to his new job
and I brought in the scene that Zachary
recommends it's if you look in the
background if you look to the left of
the screen when we show this clip we've
looped it so you can catch it a couple
times there is a guy in the background
as hope drives by on his motorcycle who
was really either a pissed off at his
dog or really really tired of owning
this dog
they are by the there by the ocean it
takes place on the seashore and see if
you can catch what happens in this [__]
that should not be from mr. nanny now
that's Bowie
that's the Bowie clip again that's the
big sideburns clip this is the DVR here
so I don't want I think this would be
the one we're looking for
I think that's mr. nanny nope
yeah whether it be the doors maybe track
maybe chapter four maybe it would be the
way to go let's try that one
[Applause]
really inappropriate
feeling inappropriate times
that's right it's a guy drowning his dog
that's what you see a guy drowning his
[__] dog the Hulkster just drives on
by he doesn't give a [__] around your
dog brother I don't care who was like
letting the Hulk Hogan do movies I gotta
kill you before he killed himself he
killed his dog yeah that happened
there's a guy drowning his dog in that
movie and it's the most entertaining
thing in that film I'll have enough I
think of the original Tyler was mr.
nanny and dr. hate they remove doctor
dr. hate drowning is his lab every week
we also try to find an a-list actor
turning in a less than a list
performance it's a segment we call
exquisite acting welcome to the world of
exquisite acting with Ralph Garman
[Music]
this week's exquisite acting features
one of my favorite actors of all time
Sean Connery that's right you should
[__] applaud I'm a brilliant [__]
actor what could I have done in any film
that you have a problem with Ralph
Garman well Sean if you want me to leave
seem to have everything handled yourself
a little piece for my one-man show I
mean you're not gonna sing you know
going to do the other half of the show
you're [__] sit there suck your own
tits and dick cuz that's what you're
good
I'll be Sean Connery okay you and I'll
be me well Sean you did turn in a little
less than great performance in this
particular film
[Laughter]
Sean Connery is bein in the movies
called first night okay from 1995 he
played an older Arthur plays King Arthur
to Richard Gere's Lancelot I know should
be another guy drowning his dog in this
movie Julia or mom guy goes through more
dogs Julia Ormond plays the lovely
Guinevere and King Arthur
[Laughter]
the dog
[Applause]
we gotta get some more of that Skywalker
[Laughter]
lordy
King Arthur finds out that his trusted
friend and a knight of the round table
Lancelot is in love with and sleeping
with his beloved Guinevere that is true
and in this scene and we've looped this
again so you can see it a few times
because it just gets better
Arthur is in his Chapel and he is
questioning why this is happening to him
right and so this is Shaun Shaun Connor
is exquisite acting performance in the
movie first night I can watch that all
[__] night I could just I can leave
the stage sit here with you and just
watch that over and over again why that
is his version of the [__] Vader
[Music]
solar tea of course the the meets of
Hollywood babble-on each and every week
Kevin I like to comment on the showbiz
news of the week it's a segment we call
the HBO headlines
[Music]
HBO headlines this week Kevin and I
would like to personally thank Amanda
Bynes for the housewarming gift
apparently she knew it was our first
show in a new club and she wanted to
make us feel at home so she went batshit
crazy I think it's only appropriate we
give her a tribute first and foremost
with her theme so absolutely any it's
gonna happen roughly I know where's that
dog I'm gonna
[Music]
this week amanda Bynes was in the lobby
of her apartment building smoking pot
you know like you do so the doorman
calls the cops smoke in front of [__]
people and in public areas and shakes
right do it up in your room she couldn't
wait to get to her apartment so she had
to start smoking in the lobby that's
[__] weird by the time the police
arrived she was already in her apartment
on the 36th floor of this high-rise in
New York City the cops knocked she opens
up she welcomes them in foolishly
because when the cop says hey that's a
bong and a man that grid takes the bong
and throws it out the [__] window
note isn't what bomb the one you just
threw out the window ma'am 36th floor
mind you that's dangerous man
I mean you throw a penny off the 36th
floor you could [__] break somebody's
skull in so you throw a bomb
particularly what kind of bong is a
glass as metals made of wood did
somebody make it in I have an apple is
it a is it a human skull it's made from
a dead dog so the officers arrest her
for reckless endangerment first of all
being in somebody with a bong from 36
floors yes that's that's dangerous
dangerous tampering with evidence
because the cop says oh there's a pong
I'm going to arrest you and that's my
evidence that she throws it out the
[__] window yeah now you got no
evidence been ever doing that like we
got a cop downstairs he just caught it
your and criminal possession of
marijuana apparently she wasn't supposed
to have it now this one I'm very
interested I'm sure you are so that just
means again you know if you're out there
[__] flaunting it and smoking in the
lobby so much so that the doorman calls
the cops that's you're not supposed to
do that don't even do it do it on the
down-low exactly so she is arrested and
according to sources
she was screaming while they were
arresting her my favorite celebrity
phrase of all time
don't you know who I am which I'm sure
the cop said yes that's why we're
[__] taking you in menace she was
taken to Roosevelt Hospital where she
underwent a psychiatric evaluation and I
can't believe they let her go but she
did go to a midtown police station she
was booked and they took her mugshot
have you've seen the mug sure and I do
some a favor go home and Google the mug
shot because they took her wig off and
yes she was arraigned in a wig yeah
rains in a wig over her face I don't
mean like the Herod I think it slipped
down over her face and then they took it
out for the mugshot and then she went
put it back on again for the judge which
made her look like a crack [__] she had
like janky fingernails he was like
missing acrylics and everything she's
like I'm okay
Helen Mirren came in and she thought it
was the cream that's all [__] up she
was Your Majesty
the judge let her go on her own
recognizance what's going on in New York
City by the way no man knows about
hospital let's go back on the street the
judge says just go home but come back
when we have to arraign you for all this
stuff by the way she told the court that
the bong that the police say they saw
her throw out the window was not a bomb
she said it was just a vase so we'll
follow this case very closely but God
bless you Amanda for all that you've
done it looks like she may finally be
getting help she needs though man
like now that well now that she's been
arrested and they're good like she's
going like I've read stories about the
follow-up where the judge out here is
like look she's on probation so she's
now she got to come back out here and
answer to probation violations that she
did on the other side of the country
which means she could be looking at
$1,000 fine which is nothing worst and
six months in jail well for just for
going for being caught with weed in New
York instead
well she tweeted this evening on if you
saw it or not she tweeted that she
doesn't smoke weed all she smokes is
tobacco and that she doesn't know what
they're talking about right
yeah they absolutely deny deny deny
that's the plan but that ain't true we
all know she's smokin weed yeah well
maybe she threw it out the window she
threw it back go out the window along
with everything else
heats up hopefully she's gonna go Joe
Francis you familiar with him girls gone
wild guy while we're looking at the the
court docket here he was found guilty on
May 6th of three counts of false
imprisonment he met three girls students
at a bar and took them to his house and
wouldn't let them leave what a piece of
[__] he is a foul human being yeah
I mean so he made his fortune being foul
human being why is anybody's [__]
surprised the guy who made a living with
a handycam and and telling girls the
girls gone wild he has decided that it's
the jury's fault that he's going to have
to pay the price for this particular
crime did an interview this week with
The Hollywood Reporter and I just want
to read some quotes what he said about
the jury that convicted him I want that
jury to know that each and every one of
them are mentally [__] [__] and
you should be euthanized because as
Darwin said you have naturally selected
yourself I'm pretty sure Darwin never
says he's like no not Charles Darwin
Eddie Darwin my neighbor guy I buy weed
from I call him Darwin he's gotta like
my Kramer
you are the weakest members of the herd
goodbye and if that jury wants to
convict me because I didn't show up
which is the only reason they did then
you know they should all be lined up and
shot now what happens he's convicted in
absentia he wasn't there he's saying he
didn't show up for the trial his lawyer
was representing him he didn't appear
and so he's claiming that's why they
found him guilty because he wasn't in
the courtroom doesn't really lend to
your innocence I feel like I'm not going
to [__] that [__] were asked him to
be imprisoned what happens now
well they still have a sentencing
hearing to go they don't know what
they're gonna do with it he wasn't even
involved in the trial he's now do you
think he'll show up for the sentencing
no I think he has to I think you have to
be there have to be present when he has
his own Island doesn't he yeah I think
he does so I mean couldn't he just
escaped to his own Island I suppose he
could I wonder if the authorities are
aware of that I hope so I was on a plane
with this [__] dude once really I had
no idea make you lift your top duty
record you yeah what about these pressed
him against the glass
he was sitting behind me and he'd
[__] spose from New York to Los
Angeles I know he was but for the first
three hours all he did was berate
everybody around him this [__] plane
the government the courts because they
wouldn't let him take his private jet
back he had to fly commercially and he
was still in first class but he was
bitching about the whole way then he was
one of those guys that used the phone on
the plane and loudly talked about big
money deals and [__] and again I didn't
know who he was then when we got out the
airport people were to take his picture
and I asked one of the persons who was
that guy like that's the dude from girls
gone wild Joe Francis but he was not
like an upstanding citizen monster now
he's a piece of [__] he goes on to say
he goes on to say about the the jury
anybody who criticizes me is just
jealous everybody who says Oh Joe
Francis is this look at their penis and
tell me if it's small see a [__]
fourteen-year-old girl fighting on
Instagram
juries hate me because they want my life
I have private jets I have a great life
I'm good-looking I'm not conceited but
like look I have girls around me all the
time whenever I want I make a lot of
money it's a great life if I wasn't me
I'd [__] hate me I mean at least he
knows who he is
if I was him I'd [__] hate me that's
the thing meanwhile all this good stuffs
happening all these people are getting
in trouble getting all the attention
going into court with their wigs on
wrong and stuff and poor is stuck in
rehab what's she supposed to do well I'm
but not for God she's got some [__]
going on yeah Lindsay's being sued by a
clothing company she was in business
with she released her own fashion line
and she sued them first initially saying
you didn't give me enough money for my
royalties you still owe me money
they countersued by saying you're such a
mess no one will buy your clothes
basically they are suing her because
they said and this is from the court
document her drug addled image hurt the
business so badly that no one would
touch her clothing line now let me tell
you what this clothing one was amongst
other things she also does she designed
leggings that had kneepads sewn into
them I'm not kidding this was a real
thing you're not gonna buy them from
Lindsay Lohan who would you buy them
from I would love another drink thank
you that's a Jack Daniels and club soda
thank you good thank you don't mind us
for just placing an order meanwhile
she's in Betty Ford Clinic and they've
taken away her adderall that with her
clothes these days no it's an actual
drug that she takes she claims for her
ADHD oh that's right she was saying I'm
gonna need to take this wherever I go
because she says she's hyperactive which
happens when you do a lot of blow you
get hyperactive so they've taken it away
from her and insiders say she looks and
this is their quote bloated Haggard
hasn't brushed her hair in days and has
no energy also what happens when you
stop doing blow by
and then she actually told Pierce Morgan
interview before she went in that she
had only done cocaine four or five times
ever ever or that ever and just bad luck
the cops caught her two out of those
four times doing the blow her drug
dealer has gone to Star magazine what's
just made it just hurts my heart because
if you can't trust your drug dealer to
keep his [__] mouth shut who can you
trust he told the magazine that he sold
her personally between ten and fifteen
thousand dollars worth of cocaine over a
long period of time and also Molly which
is a pharmaceutical grade ecstasy I've
never heard of those any seven name a
girl's name Molly yes em oh yeah you're
gonna place an order
did you spell that for me what is that
Molly all right I'm gonna hello pink doc
do you have Molly the guy said he ended
up ending their business relationship
and this was his quote because I'm not
in the business of helping people kill
themselves a drug dealer said that oh
man you know how bad you gotta be for
your drug dealer to be like look she's a
mess yeah I know I sell you dangerous
pharmaceuticals but I'm worried about
your health because you're doing a lot
of drugs so she may have done drugs more
than once or twice as all we're saying I
think so I think it's a safe assumption
meanwhile pop scrotum Justin Bieber is
also having a bad week have you guys saw
the Billboard Music Awards last weekend
we have a theme song for him oh yeah we
got a little we got a little Bieber song
let's see let's hear a little
[Music]
nobody [__] eat
you're a little [__]
[Applause]
pop scrotum one the milestone award at
the Billboard Music Awards this weekend
the milestone award is for someone who
has reinvented music who has sir I do I
must I remind you baby baby baby oh
thank you so much but just a moment for
appreciation of [__] [__] excellent
inflection so he wins the milestone
award which I feel [__] up the
Billboard Music Awards are first of all
but when he won a large percentage of
the audience if you watch the show you
saw this booed him when he hit the stage
I've heard I would see did you bring a
clip I brought a clip this is just a
tail end of the booing but I brought in
the clip to show you his speech which
was very defiant he was very pissed off
the people were booing him he was
wearing his sunglasses indoors like a
[__] douchebag and he said the
following 19 years old I'm 19 years old
I think I think I'm doing a pretty good
job
and basically from my heart I really
just want to say its issue it should
really be about the music it should be
about the craft the craft that I'm that
I'm making this is not this is not a
gimmick I'm not I'm not a gimmick guy
I'm I'm an artist and I should be taking
seriously and this all this other bull
should not be spoken on yeah yeah the
minute you say I'm an artist and I
should be taken seriously
you know what [__] take you seriously
what a little [__] dick look man like
I'm not usually trying to get the dudes
back or their err on the side of course
but that is just [__] like you got
that many people booing at you and
you're like hey man I'm only 19 remember
all this talent money only 19 is a
miracle and and all this other all this
other bull shouldn't be spoken of yeah
well then we'll all just be quiet and
I'm sorry sorry Justin
and also Justin your [__] white
little reminder Canadian [__] white
Canadian from Canada who's white when
did you become Kanye West all of a
sudden no no no good I'm an artist and
no no no I should be taken seriously and
all this other bull should not be spoken
of
the gay and it'll make police go Habs yo
I think any minute he's also bound to
get a visit from Helen Mirren as the
visa Justin
I saw your clip you're challenged
meanwhile sad news beepers monkey yeah
by the way great band saw them at the
troubadour last weekend
Bieber's monkey is now officially a
citizen of Germany another monkey sauce
yeah yeah we love him more than that
little boy yeah
experimenting in order to make it a
super monkey yeah yeah he left his
monkey in Germany like we do in Munich
at the airport they stopped him they
said this monkey can without his papers
a kid yeah your papers they love their
[__] papers those Germans yeah give
him papers yeah they put a little banana
shaped star on his chest and put him in
this game
it was the [__] 40s come on really
geez all right Schindler he left it
behind those left they said you can come
back and pick it up when your way out of
the country feel free to stop by and
pick up Molly your monkey yeah what if
Molly's named after the drug out of the
monkey it's the monkey juice yeah he's
good to make you high you get [__] up
on Molly
so he never came back for it and now the
monkey belongs to Germany now were they
gonna do put him in a zoo they said no
because they're afraid that if they if
people find out justin bieber's monkeys
in a zoo that deranged Bieber fans will
come to the zoo and molest the monkey
because it's Bieber's and I mean molest
by you know throwing [__] at him and
stuff it out and I mean like this kind
of molester so they're gonna put it in a
primate rescue facility Oh which I'm
sure just littered Germany with tons of
those I'm sure there's a lot of apes are
running around there like he's the only
one in there that's right and it's less
a reserve and more unused a boxcar
that's where we're gonna put it in could
you imagine your this monkey and you're
just like holy [__] man I got stripped
from my [__] parents now I belong to
this [__] now his [__] abandoned
me in Germany right I hate this monkey
he's only twenty weeks old oh [__] which
luckily for him is old enough to drink
in Germany so he's gonna have a great
Oktoberfest Farrah Abraham the the
backdoor Teen Mom it is why did call it
back to our teen thank you so much why
do you say backdoor to you because
that's the name of her [__] movie the
movie is called back to her teen that's
right it's called backdoor Teen Mom
Farrah Abraham backdoor Teen Mom because
she was a teen mom on MTV and she she
achieved fame by pooping a human out of
her vagina and so naturally she deserves
fame and fortune and now she's doing
porn
hence the vector hence the backdoor Teen
Mom and which I even tweeted this to her
personally I said you know at your first
movie you don't give up the [__]
really
you save that for the sequel that's just
a rookie mistake really you have to you
have to save something for the second
instead of somewhere to go that's right
we're gonna go now yeah it's actually
drill a hole in her body someplace to
make it more interesting or airtight
that'd be a good one airtight team mom
I'd rent that so vivid entertainment who
will release the film put her bikini up
for auction on eBay and they made a
point of specifying in the posting on
eBay in the listing that it was unwashed
so there was somebody who's like I'll
pay more yeah really yeah that's a hot
market and it started off at five
hundred dollars went to fourteen
thousand seven hundred dollars in
bidding who do you have it all right no
no one has it because eBay pulled the
listing they cancelled the auction Oh
finally [__] right due to and I quote
this from eBay health and hygiene
concerns that's true now I think about
it it's not like eBay is not littered
with buy my panties now so why would she
get away with it or why would they get
away it's a big no-no on eBay to sell
used panties or swimsuits so they hold
the auction so no one has won the
bathing suit it is all depressing that
it went that high yeah
yeah no one knows where the suit is now
because Vivat had it in a steel lock box
in a vault but apparently it ate through
all of the metal and it's just sinking
its way through the Earth's crust and no
one knows where it's gonna end ah sick
bay celebrity sick bay George Michael
legendary George Michael from Wham of
course a huge solo career the 90s that
sort of disappeared in a cloud of
marijuana dust and men he's been having
problems he's lately they've been
finding him asleep at the wheel and
traffic and stuff he's apparently gets
very stoned and or very drunk they're
not really sure and then has problems
with his automobile
he drives himself which is not a good
idea they found him on the m1 motorway
in England this wee
he had a bad accident they had to
airlift him off of the motorway and take
him to the hospital and a bad head
injury initially no one was saying what
had happened well it comes out this week
that George Michael it's not funny but
George Michael all right it's a little
bit funny George Michael fell out of his
SUVs open door while it was going 70
miles per hour
you're [__] do you think he was
trying to kill us nobody knows what
happened how does the door just open man
like that's a conscious thing I I don't
know whether he was trying to - I won't
say that but he got a he got a head
injury that's all I'm saying that's it
now he does or he had one before well
the guy who giving him head I think also
got injured now no one knows why the
door opened or why he fell out at 70
miles an hour but they're currently
investigating and George is still in the
hospital
he does not want to be a father figure
that's all I'm telling you more sad
Medical News Tim Curry one of my
favorite actors Tim Curry had a stroke
last I heard 67 year old actor probably
best known still as dr. Frank and
further from Rocky Horror Picture Show
was that character sound like now or
then first
oh now here comes your trifecta hell no
the good news is he can speak his his
people are saying he's okay he can speak
he can communicate not too much damage
from the stroke luckily for me because
my impression would be shot to hell with
you I'm just a sweet transvestite from
place pick him oh hey hey basically I
Knight you he's going to recover they
say we hope so
yes his speech has not been impaired not
been impaired now how do you do I see
you've met my faithful handyman he's
just a bit put out because when you
knocked he thought you were the Candyman
I'm just a sweet transvestite from
transsexual Transylvania now we play the
real version if I remember correctly we
don't have the C you get to carry tuned
for ten minutes and don't have to be
verified with the real track afterwards
more music news Jada pinkett-smith an
interview this week and her daughter's
name came up Willow you remember she
whipped her hair back and forth yeah
yeah she was supposed to be in the the
remake of Annie that her father Will
Smith is doing with jay-z is it always
all black cast and your suggestive title
was Danny
but Willow backed out of it saying that
she just wanted to be 12 she just want
to be a 12 year old and she didn't want
to be in the movie good choice for her
and Will and Jada Smith are still
beating her over that I just pulled a
Joe Jack sitted with the belt adjust so
they did an interview with Jada Pinkett
Smith this week and they said by the way
what happened with willow and tani
wasn't she supposed to be in that and
this is what were you conducting the
interview this is her quote she's just
developing herself she's taking her time
to develop her skills so when she feels
like people are ready to know the real
willow then she will make her comeback
how old is she she's 12 and she's
working on her comeback she's already
been to the heights crash - now she her
mom is pushing her for the comeback I
heard you the first time
family services should be notified
someone should go to the Smith house and
pull that child out I just imagined her
just like being forced to tap dance for
hours on end in front of a mirror I want
to see your tattoo it's oppression more
shitty music news Britney Spears has new
music
I know we've missed her haven't we she
is her first single since 2011 it's been
a long time since she's released new
music this is a single that she recorded
for the Smurfs 2 soundtrack when's that
happening because I want to make sure
I'm out of the country
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the new track is called Lala and I know
you're desperately want to hear a little
piece of the new Britney Spears [__] yes
man let's know the enemy no no that
shouldn't be spoken of here's a little
taste of the new single specifically for
the children's movie Smurfs to keep that
in mind as you listen to you la la by
Britney Spears
[Music]
Smurfs - yeah children will see the
movie and they'll hear the lyrics take
my hand and we can go all night spin me
around just the way I like mom should I
[__] a smurf yes yes you should never
fall over her face oh my lord that's not
for a children's movie no it's barely
for an adults film spinning around part
just sounds so athletic tiring with a
smurf it's possible man because there's
just you're wearing it like a blue
condom anyway they just spin that
[__] round
I'm flashlight Smurf I'm sperm bank
Smurf sometimes in the news we hear
about movies that are upcoming that I
can guarantee you just from hearing the
premise will [__] suck that's why we
have a segment each and every week
called movies that will suck
[Music]
say oh my god that's [__] what the
[__] they're movies bad will suck yeah
[Applause]
Arnold Schwarzenegger is in negotiations
to star in a remake of the classic cult
film the toxic avenger the Terminator is
gonna play Toxie No oh it gets shittier
oh the toxic avenger proposed you don't
know is a classic z grade film from
Troma the first a superhero from New
Jersey that's right he was a janitor who
fell into a drum of toxic chemicals that
turned him into a mutant super-powered
hero who basically if I remember the
film correctly would just stab a lot of
people with a broom handle yeah yeah
this yes sir this they're gonna remake
it and this is gonna be a 17 year old
high school student this time it gets
dumped in the toxic chemicals makes
sense you always want to go younger
that's right even if your hero's a
mutant that's right and shorts Integra
will play the former black ops agent who
trains him to use his powers for good
okay that wasn't in the first no it was
not no he didn't have a sensi trainer no
he didn't the character's name in toxic
avenger 4 Schwarzenegger will be the
exterminator why not just go the
distance call him governor exterminator
yeah I trained you what you do you take
your maid and you put your penis inside
of her you put a baby down and then you
spend the rest of your life apologizing
to your wife with a giant chin there
needs to be one scene where the [__]
young toxic avenger comes to them and
says look at this lump is this a tumor
it's not a tumor
not at all greatest callback in movie
history exactly because Kevin and I are
such geeks every week we'd like to touch
on what we lovingly refer to as the geek
news
[Applause]
this week's key this week's geek news
Damon Lindelof one of the writer
directors producers rather of star trek
into darkness got a lot of [__] from
Star Trek fans because the one smart
female character in the film dr. Carol
Marcus played by Alice Eve early on in
the movie strips down to her underwear
okay and women truck fans especially are
saying it was gratuitous and demeaning
to have I didn't say it wasn't it was
first of all Alice Eve has amazing tits
so I didn't mind but it did seem a
little odd she's like so Captain Kirk
we've got a big problem excuse me well I
get out of these clothes and she changes
her costume while Kirk is in the room of
course being Kirk II takes a glance
behind them you know he jerked off in
the moon no I'm kidding because I was
gonna leave here and go see it now I was
like finally they're taking my notes
penis for jizz he did apologize via
Twitter he said I copped to the fact
that we should have done a better job of
not being gratuitous in our
representation of a barely clothed
actress so exactly yes do it and
apologize yeah
phasers to come Star Wars news JJ Abrams
apparently in talks with an actor to
star in the next trilogy of Star Wars
films and who is it this comes from a
Latino review which although you
wouldn't guess it by the name has
excited has a remarkable record when it
comes to the scoops about and he did
they do a lot of research except they've
broken a lot of stories the Latino
review says that JJ Abrams gonna cast
George Lopez as the lead
órale Darth vader-like old Darkseid and
[__] no Jonathan Rhys Meyers from the
tutors apparently going to take the lead
in the next trilogy he of course if it
happens will be starring with the
original cast Mark Hamill Carrie Fisher
and Harrison so he might be their kid
young Luke Skywalker or so on and Leah
had a kid yeah I don't know if they're
gonna do the extended universe stuff
they've done in the books or whatnot or
if they're just gonna create their own
but seems like if you look at him he
kind of little bit resembles I will keep
wanting to say Mark Hamill or Luke
Skywalker but he didn't have a kid no I
think it would be Han and Leia's kid you
think so yeah I hope it is because I
want to see the scene where he sits down
and with Han Solo and dad Kazuma talking
to about things like may the force be
with you no credits as they say while
we're talking about Mark Hamill Mark
Hamill's pants from the first Star Wars
movie went up for auction this week and
one of those celebrity and memorabilia
auctions and they thought it was going
to watched her own wash she said yeah
they I believe were washed the original
pants he wore throughout the entire
first film went up for auction
they thought they were he's gonna get a
couple hundred thousand dollars for it
end up going just for $36,000 which
sounds like a lot of money but in
reality when it comes to that kind of
memorabilia they were expecting a lot
more yeah for especially for like hero
pants are worn by the hero characters
I was wondering especially because
they've been up against Luke's dick a
good point closest you'll ever get to
Luke's dick I'd like to ask a question
do these pants actually touch Luke's
dick
if not I'm not interested may I smell
them first I don't care what it smells
like get in there sick of watching The
Big Bang Theory it turns out that the
pants worn by Mark Hamill in the first
Star Wars movie were tan Levi's they
were just regular Levi's jeans
tanley if you look at him anyway they
was just they just bought Levi's and put
him on him and that's what he wore in
the first movie really that's what
they're like [__] that am i paying money
for the pair of tan Levi's I don't care
who wore him so they were very
disappointed with the auction Andrew
Garfield was seen shooting hoops with
kids this week in New York cities seen
the photos dress the spiders dressed as
spider-man how cool is that
he's shooting in Manhattan there's some
kids in the Chinatown neighborhood he
was he was shooting nearby and they're
shootin hoops so he comes over in the
spider-man costume and started shooting
hoops with him it was pretty amazing
many of your kid and you're shooting
hoops oh I'm a spider-man comes up I
guess I would be a Hollywood helper yeah
although I know he did shoot web fluid
all over them I understand so it's kind
of distasteful no no that's really a
helper it's just like it's funny was
having fun it's not like man without my
help these kids wouldn't have played
basket yeah that's true if anything kids
are like we hated it like he's taller he
took our ball we were in the middle of a
game
hey Spidey we're playing horse [__] off
jonah Jameson's right he's a menace and
this story broke my heart the guy in
Minnesota is a contractor he buys houses
to flip him which in motus Minnesota now
you can buy a house for like I think 25
bucks and he can get a house so he
bought a house and he was renovating it
to flip it and sell it again and he's
tearing down walls and his this wall and
back in the olden times before the
advent of insulation they would stuff
the walls with newspaper and [__] so
he's breaking down the drywall and out
flops a copy of Action Comics number one
from 1938 the first appearance of
Superman
now the comic book is a little bit torn
up it's not in beautiful shape but they
said it was you know in comic books you
rate comics from like a zero to a ten
yeah they said he had a three on his
hands which they a mint almost mint
condition I think recently went for
auction for over two million dollars yes
so they said this was like a $200,000
comic book you found in the wall so he's
very excited and he goes home to his
wife and his white aunt his wife's aunt
who lives with them and he's very
excited talk with a cowboy she goes let
me see that and she grabs the comic book
and tears the back cover of the comic
which sends it from a 3 to a 1.5 and
dropped the price he eventually sold a 4
for $75,000 how do you not have that
fight for the rest of your life that
happened to me I would never stop peeing
on that woman I would come home from
work at the end the day oh I was just
urinate all over her why is he doing
that to you because I tore his comic
book and then I'd kill my [__] dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
each and every week folks we like to
explore the mystery that is Liam
Neeson's [__] as you know as you know
Kevin has had a fixation for a long time
about the size of Liam Neeson's [__] it
is legendary and you could people have
been going now for jeez a couple years
you've been going to Neeson [__] calm
and adding your own facts about Liam
Neeson's [__] that's why we call the
segment just how big is Liam Neeson's
[__] Liam Neeson's [__] is so big that
while visiting the Hall of Justice Liam
got an erection and the superfriends
decided that Apache chief was out of a
job Liam Neeson's [__] is so big when he
gets morning wood Cirque de Soleil sets
up under his bed sheet that's cute you
can tell your mother that joke I know
about mourning boners Tiger
we've had that conversation Liam
Neeson's [__] is so big that it doesn't
just read books it interrogate the book
until the book gives the information up
it's looking for Liam Neeson's [__] is
so big if you mix diet coke and mentos
inside of it nothing happens
[Laughter]
hit my sweet spot everywhere I was like
I've done that Liam Neeson's [__] is so
big if you search for it on Google's
directions the response is second star
to the right strain on until morning
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big he started
a rescue for orphaned baby kangaroos
under his foreskin looks like a pouch
they just stay there they curl up to
feed him with a little baby bottle they
kick though you don't want then Liam
Neeson's [__] is so big it takes the
cleaning staff three hours just to do
the lobby Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
he doesn't have a Prince Albert he has a
Fat Albert
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
to ditch the evidence Amanda Bynes threw
her bomb down his urethra
ladies the gentlemen of the improv have
you had a good time to save them thank
you for being here for our inaugural
voyage thank you for selling us out man
and then join us next week we'll be back
here next week new home man so join us
as we come back every week from now on a
fami Ron and I would like to thank our
amazing emcee master of ceremonies give
it up for Ralph [__] czar thank you
sir
and thanks to my good friend and partner
mr. Kevin Smith and that is Hollywood
babble-on for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman hobble the [__]
[Applause]
[Music]